good morning John 2008 I met a video
called the Anna Grumman guide to the
presidential elections in which I
anagram to the names of presidential
candidates and give up with funny things
and then like a week later the Daily
Show anagrams the names of presidential
candidates and I was like wow I mostly I
was just excited that the Daily Show
thought I was worth stealing from but
then John you being you because you're a
writer and you have lots of writer
friends were able to determine that in
fact The Daily Show had written that
segment before I wrote mine people have
ideas concurrently all the time the
certain number the people who have those
ideas will actually execute those ideas
leading to a debate over who thought of
it first billion productive and
uninteresting and then I get tweets or
tumblr messages from people who are like
ah target stole your draft love thing no
they didn't a designer had the same idea
that I did the giraffe could make hearts
with their necks and I am more power to
him I'm all for artists making living
moving back into the past even further
here in 2007 John your friend Katie else
put dftba on the end of her to-do list
we stole that from her popularized it
through this video blog and now dftba is
a thing that i'm proud of and that i
identify with and lots of people make
dftba stuff some of those people are
just crafty creative people on Etsy and
some of them are big global corporations
are those people stealing from us are
they stealing from Katy are they
stealing from no one personally I like
it when it's stuff that I like like this
sone greeting card buy so cute by Krista
on Etsy and then I don't like it when
it's stuff that I don't really like like
this shirt from Delia's that also in
addition to saying don't forget to be
awesome says Keep Calm and party on one
meme wasn't enough but there's a
difference between having a sense of
ownership over something like I do over
dftba and actually owning it I
personally don't want to cave in to that
desire for control I've been able to
create a really cool project based on
the work of another creator that creator
being Jane Austen who I do not put
myself on the same level with to be
clear and Walt Disney interestingly did
the same thing with Alice in Wonderland
in The Little Mermaid in Cinderella
those were all stories before Disney
came along and made them into movies now
Disney has turned and is the primary
force behind extending the copyright
length forever
good news is the Internet is making all
of this obsolete fewer and fewer
corporations are enforcing copyright in
the way that they used to there's just
too much derivative work going on I
remember when wizard-rock was first
happening and like the publishing
companies behind Harry Potter were like
no you can't make derivative works based
on Harry Potter you can't make Harry
Potter songs and yeah you can why would
you stop people from being enthusiastic
about your creations ah now when
somebody posts a lip-synch video of One
Direction the video doesn't get taken
down YouTube's algorithms identify it as
a One Direction song advertisements pop
up on it and Sony Music International
gets the money from those advertisements
this is not law in fact it's not really
legal but the lip-sync person gets to
keep having their video online and One
Direction gets to make money and
everybody's happy so the law doesn't
really come into it it's kind of
corporations deciding what's okay and
what isn't which is worrisome almost all
creations before you know seventeen
hundred were collaborative creation a
song could be written by dozens of
different people over hundreds of years
and the Internet is again full of things
like that creations that are about
making people happy or making them laugh
or making them think or getting a
reaction not about increasing personal
wealth or controlling creative vision
ideas being free might not be good for
the pocketbooks of individuals scattered
around the world but it is better for
society and culture as a whole that's
what makes life beautiful Oh John I'll
see you on Monday I actually will be
seeing John on Monday that wasn't a
screw-up and I may be seeing you as well
because we're having to pre Carnegie
rehearsal shows in New York tickets are
$10 all proceeds go to charity
link in the description bye